hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction okay got
my portal potion here you know oh okay I
don't need to splash it on the door or
anything turn the door into a portal cuz
that would make total sense all right
guess I'm going here oh no I do not like
this already I can tell this is
something that I'm not gonna like uh of
course of course it is of course it was
so bright and welcoming why would they
leave it that way
[Music]
okay tinderbox oil box oh thank you for
the oil so tired of not having oil okay
maybe I should just spend oh no no no
hello hello get out of here get out of
here nope nope no I refuse oh what's
that oh you're skinny bastard you can't
hurt me Oh
get out of here it's a different one
today make a new monster for this mud
whatever whatever get out of here go
away okay
always good little sunlit Oh take me
away
get me out of here out of here five
siblings born Duke seventh province
lavish luxury three God's festivals this
is bad huh struck by a Terry Puhl see
kab is that it come okay see kab RSD I
could tell a code when I see one see ka
b r SD c k AV or SD okay remembered
instant memory miss miss no no of course
not why would they all right come on guy
I'm a punchy in-your-face
scrawny little bastard
come here okay
um what's that huh let their fate guide
you whose fate uh I don't know how would
I know
um 9 neatly stacked puck Oh what the
hell
9 6 okay like a number-pad oil oil
didn't the boxes they give me all these
tinderboxes but hardly any torches to
use them on I mean really okay um just I
need these for the other room ah nope
nope nope nope get out of here ah it's
right there get out of here get out of
here I tossed the box don't come in here
don't come in here guy seriously guy
Oh seriously God seriously seriously I
do it's a bad juju in here it's bad it's
bad bad go over there [ __ ] off yeah okay
Oh smart throw it in the same room that
I'm in good job me
thanks be all for this back off back off
sound different every other guy what are
you
[Music]
oh okay all right I think he's gone okay
all better Niner
hey do I need to drag all these boxes
over there God they do not like to make
things easy on me
I couldn't these boxes be in the same
room
why make nine of them whatever they
don't they're not letters so actually
before I even do this I'm gonna look
what's in here cuz maybe I'm going about
it yeah oh oh I do not like this I don't
like inanimate objects anything under
the stairs no nothing of course uh I
don't like that
me no likey oh there's something under
the stairs
yay okay finally this whole lotta nothin
got better go back to a box tossing
that's my favorite pastime
go one read oh maybe the the letters
that I got don't do that
maybe the letters that I got
corresponding numbers somehow get over
there over there get get get get get on
the champion box toss oh my go world
circuit championship box toss it Harlan
cubes yeah yeah you got that reference
high five to you
the very recent reference pollen cubes
okay let their fate guide you okay what
do we got here eight go right there
eight I don't know I don't know okay let
me read my note they were struck by a
terrible storm ripping them to pieces
since Sibley home unable to provide for
themselves and they all eventually
paired okay one two three four five six
seven eight
CAPITAL LETTERS oh w-was one two three
four five six seven eight nine okay
there are nine capital letters and I
have nine boxes and there are four
pedestals this makes no sense
I am at a loss oh well they're just
tossing boxes probably isn't even right
oh I don't even know if these boxes are
supposed to be here and Boop okay yeah I
win oh look at me let me double-check
that other room maybe sure it would suck
it really suck if I had to toss all the
boxes back here wouldn't it guys
wouldn't that just be the worst ha ha ha
okay umm umm umm umm it was a big long
hallway but I didn't really check if
there are any side rooms almost too busy
running away okay there's these creepy
ladies statues very disproportionately
figured
there's something there's eight statues
- of those statues pile a rope four
piles of rope eighty seven bottles okay
and let me check this other room just
one more time just to be sure do my due
diligence gravy gravy gravy good luck
finding this thing anywhere in here cuz
big room can't find a damn thing I'm
screwed aren't I guys I'm screwed
this puzzles gonna take me forever let
their fate guide me what do you mean
but talk about anything up okay looks
like pressure plates perhaps part of a
code um co2 co2 code
Cody code code blahblahblah Bria wck a
br s da whack bards
wack bards
Rask dad okay
oh boy oh there's a clue in here
somewhere I'm just not seeing it I am
not seeing it he'll three God's five
siblings seven properties maybe that's
it oh five seven maybe that was a red
herring five seven three five seven nine
five seven three nine
maybe that's it maybe oh five seven okay
sevens in the right spot nine okay now
it goes over here this was five okay
five okay
okay four three five seven three three
okay give me give me give me give me oh
please let this be right three nine damn
it darn it
I thought for sure that was it damn I
get it right five seven did I did I read
that right
am I just stupid carry remember anything
five seven three nine yeah those it damn
it
five seven three
all right ah all right screwed something
up or that's just was completely wrong
damn it maybe it maybe it did open the
door and I don't know I don't know I
don't know let me in out in out in out
ha oh maybe there's a lever for that
door somewhere in here I just missed it
cuz I'm an idiot anything anything
anything useful oh okay
alright I'm just gonna pause it here and
I'm gonna figure this out in the
downtime and cut back to it when I've
got the answer so I don't waste you guys
time
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you in the next part
bye bye